the temptation to do the cliche getting
out of bed with the alarm clock going
off for a day in the life video was very
real
but i won't put you guys through that
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
thomage and welcome back to the channel
if you're new here firstly thank you so
much for joining me on this channel we
talk about technology and
architecture because right now in 2021
i'm a registered architect in the state
of western australia
so every morning my day starts at 5 30
a.m
the alarm goes off i get up and within
10 to 15 minutes i'm out the door
going to the gym the gym is only about 5
minutes away
so it is very conveniently located which
means i don't have to get up
super super early my workout goes from
anywhere from half an hour to 45 minutes
sometimes even an hour
most of the times on wednesdays it is an
hour because that is leg day for me
so the first hour of my day up until
about seven o'clock
is spent working out personally i
believe i have somewhat stressful
job which requires a lot of my mental
focus and a lot of capabilities
and then i have a whole bunch of
workload pressure from my own personal
businesses
that gets me very stressed so making
sure that i work out keeps that stress
load at bay and it releases those
endorphins
it helps me really focus my energy
throughout that day
and it makes sure that i'm always in
check and ready to go i'm usually at
home and showered before seven o'clock
ready to listen to the morning stock
market podcast
i listen to the stock podcast and get
myself reacquainted with what has
happened on the stock market
overnight on the american exchange i
then simultaneously start to troll the
stock market and see what's going up
what's going down
if any day trades are possible
whatsoever and if any long-term trades
have become available
i also do this actually simultaneously
while eating breakfast
and getting ready for work so because
again i live
only five minutes away from my office it
is very close and very convenient so
therefore i don't have to leave
the house any earlier than 7 50. now
this is where i put on my architect hat
and i go to work as a business
professional
my job is as a lead design architect at
my firm
and i do a lot of design work as well as
a lot of project management
so for me a typical day will look
anything like
get to work just before 8 o'clock go
through my emails for about the first
half an hour
reply to everybody that has been in
contact with me overnight
i have a tendency to reply to all my
emails during the day
so i try to filter out the inbox and not
have hundreds of them waiting for me in
the morning then it usually proceeds
with a meeting
or two till about nine ten o'clock
sometimes it pushes through to 11
and then at that point in time i get to
do my work
so from 11 to about one i sit down i do
a lot of design or i do a lot of
documentation depending what the project
is currently
on at that time nonetheless i'm sitting
at my computer i'm sitting at my desk
i'm not out and about and then i may
potentially have lunch but most of the
times i genuinely eat lunch at my desk
and scoff it down in about five minutes
because i just don't have the time in
the day to be able to complete
all of my tasks and have the hour lunch
break that is allocated to me in my role
so if we push through one o'clock the
five minutes of the lunch break we
take on the 105 benchmark and we push
through all the way till five
this is usually either split 5050 it's
either split again
sitting at the desk sitting at the
computer designing modeling documenting
or it's split on site so usually it's
about three days out of my fortnight
that is spent project managing
so i'm out on site for those three days
you can probably equate that out to
just under half a day for an average day
throughout my day there's usually about
30 minutes to about an hour of phone
calls or
direct constant email messaging with
consultants or clients
and then there's probably another half
an hour on average per day with some
client here or there
so overall i think i get half the day to
actually sit at my desk document design
half the day to actually go to meetings
answer phone calls answer emails so for
me it's a very broad
variety of work on a day-to-day basis
but generally speaking
most of the time i am sitting at a desk
at a computer so if you're looking at
becoming an architect
make sure that you're okay with sitting
down at a desk all day every day
i know it sounds a lot easier than it is
but genuinely your body gets quite
fatigued
and you're able to put on weight so
quickly so if you aren't exercising it
ends up snowballing there as well now
depending on the workload and
the pressure at work anywhere between
october through to december i'm usually
there till about seven eight o'clock
because the workload
gets pretty intense gets pretty hectic
anywhere before
august so january through to august
october i tend to finish about 5 5
30 and then come back home i have dinner
until about six o'clock
and that's where the architecture hat
comes off and the entrepreneurial hat
comes on
and by six o'clock i'm back at this desk
doing my own
personal business so i'm either making
youtube videos like this one for you
guys
i'm checking out all my trades how they
went how they're performing
i'm replying to my own personal business
emails or i'm fulfilling orders on
another business
so for me my day usually pushes out from
that six
all the way through to about the 8 30 pm
mark
where i genuinely do try to shut off and
close the computer down because i know
if i keep pushing beyond
i will not be able to make it through
the next day and through that week i'll
always be lethargic
then i'll skip the gym and then it'll
just be a snowball effect of problems
so 8 30 will come around i will turn off
my computers
absolute latest i'll push it to 8 45
i'll have a shower and i'll try to be in
bed
by 9 pm i know this sounds like a very
grandpa
routine but it is genuinely working for
me and it is working exceptionally well
so so far i've been able to push out all
my goals and reach
everything that i've set out myself to
do in 2020 i've pushed some
even bigger goals for 2021 so i'm
definitely going to be here
every single weekend as i already am but
it is
genuinely how my day looks like every
day spans from 5 30 to 9 00 p.m and it's
on repeat
constantly and that's it guys my day is
genuinely from 5 30 to 9 00 pm
every day like clockwork it is very
important to me to keep hitting the same
goals every single day to be able to
achieve that bigger goal
i see it as progress i see it as moving
forward
so i hope you enjoyed this video if you
did make sure you smash that subscribe
button down below
because it is february you know it's 28
days
28 videos so again smash that subscribe
button help me out
produce more content as always and
because it is february
i'll see you tomorrow